Oh God how do people that do this well
do it well hi my name is Rico no no no
now you know it's different now um
that's as far as I've thought out this
video that's fine it is homecoming
season it's also Halloween season some
of you might not know what one of those
things are homecoming is a dance that
happens for high schoolers in the fall
where they had to dress up in elaborate
attire and Halloween is the same thing
that's having fun to merge the two and I
was going to recreate one of my high
school homecoming looks the first
picture I have is basically we'd look at
the comfort level of this stick bug
think this is me in ninth grade I
actually made this dress because I had a
sewing machine from jo-ann's fabric and
you can see I sort of knew how to use a
sewing machine but I did not know how to
use an iron the second look is my 10th
grade homecoming look what you yeah sir
I am sweating at New Jersey out of every
orifice in this look I did not make this
look it doesn't make this look any
better or worse but I think it was one
of the only girls at homecoming that
decided that I should have a two-piece
ensemble with texture in keeping with my
former self I went to Joanne's fabrics
and I bought some fabric I decided that
I wanted to recreate one if not both of
these iconic grace Helbig homecoming
looks that could also be used as an
iconic Halloween look go as a throwback
Thursday let's just do it
first things first going to join fabrics
to buy fabric for this type of video was
stressful I had to go buy this pink
satin fabric a lot of it and pretend
like I was doing something like normal
with it very see-through you can't
really tell how many fingers I'm holding
up just one let's get started on this
10th grade iconic grace Helbig
homecoming look I'm gonna readjust you
now whoa okay sure that's good and we're
cutting it no one looks up close it's
like every high schoolers rule of thumb
regardless of like formal dance or
whatever don't look up close okay okay
so far we might have something I also
bought handheld stitching machine which
I tested out I made
of a pillow on my couch yesterday
instead of doing any work that they
should I should have shot this video
yesterday but I didn't use this to make
my couch I also have a hot glue gun
we're just recreating I'm not actually
going to a dance in this so it doesn't
have to be functional neither were any
of the outfits that I actually created
for myself before I'm gonna put some
Spanx on and I'm gonna get some a safety
pin what a look I've been doing great
this fabric so why is this safety pin so
rusted there's a lot of questions oh
there we go
whoa beautiful princess skirt time for
this shirt every South Jersey girl's
dream in 2001 was to have a shirt that
you could pet remember those shirts that
were super tiny that you buy from Sam's
Club there look at accordions and they
become real shirts yeah this is sort of
like that but not at all so it sheds so
much and Wow also extraordinarily see
you take the girl to Jersey
you can't get the Jersey to stop trying
to make girl be a [ __ ] I'm kidding I'm
kidding I'm kidding beautiful wonderful
humans come from New Jersey mm-hmm this
is basically we like kini but will it
homecoming arm okay okay each Project
Runway also I would love to be a judge
wow that looks so good let's cut the
back of the shirt there's fur everywhere
that's my impersonation likely to
furries get together and consummate the
relationship I have no idea what this
fabric could actually be used for but I
bought it I know I'm doing this whole it
in the skirt just to prove that how
functional the skirt is guys let's hot
glue this shirt together ain't nobody
got time for it I mean you were great in
theory here we go if I'm a hot glue
warming up I pre-plan like it's off it
turned out I turned itself off oh damn
it while the hot glue is warming up
let's clean up
Wow okay so we're gonna let a beautiful
table cool down the hot glue that we're
gonna try it inside out I'm gonna
meanwhile do some quick your makeup kind
of stuff to make it look like I'm in my
10th grade
homecoming outfit none of this is
unhealthy for my growth as an adult hope
it cut it perfectly that sticks hair my
hair for this had only lived viral
little things that were hugely popular
that I had tape and extensions in the
front of my hair now that it it can't
necessarily do but let's see how we can
make something similar happen yeah I'm
sorry that your football lost but I'm
transforming myself into my 10th grade
self so there's priorities that are
happening so the top guys the top part
feels as much as I can match to my hair
at the time I don't have long hair right
now but I do have this my god let's cut
to the final product please Wow and also
wow this is taking way longer than
expected should this be a tag she's not
tagged people in this I'm gonna tag a
couple people to recreate one of their
old cringy looks whether it is a formal
dance or just a Halloween costume or
miscellaneous moment I'm gonna tag
Hannah Mary Tyler and kollene cuz
Colleen has so many photos and videos
from when she was younger what should we
call this tag this already exists I'm
sure this art is this I'm sold but Anna
yeah let me know what we should call
this tag and also let Hannah mamrie
Tyler and Colleen know that they should
participate I should describe to my
youtube channel if you haven't already
because I make all inspiring content
like that bail notification so you get
notified when I make videos because so
many of you don't get notified and this
is content you don't want to miss other
than that I don't though this has been a
lot